Agencies in the job market.
Why don't we have a Blue Seal that will allow it?
Foreign trained nurses,
doctors, engineers
and other professionals to prove they're qualified,
and within 60 days of applying to work in their field,
get a yes or no based on their
more common sense. Mr. Speaker,
this is what I'm saying here is
let's get back to the basics.
Our immigration system was the best in the world
eight years ago.
But now we have immigrants who come here
and they actually say they want to go back.
Because this is not what was promised.
I said everything is broken.
You know what is broken most of all?
The promise.
The promise of Canada.
The promise that we will reinstall.
A promise that in Canada,
it doesn't matter where you come from,
it matters where you're going.
It doesn't matter if your name is Martin or Muhammad,
whether your name is Singh or Smith,
whether your name is Chong or Charles,
whether your name is Patel or polyev.
If you work hard,
you can achieve anything you want
in the greatest country in the world.
In the freest country in the world. Mr. Speaker,
this is the common sense of the common people.
United for our common home.
Your home. My home.
Power home. Let's bring it home.